Hello everyone, good morning, welcome to the second session of today's lectures.
So here we I am going to talk about supervised machine learning which we started discussing
last week and today particularly I am going to cover decision tree and random forest.
So before that let us just get a quick recap.
I know that you have been working on this even through the hands-on tutorial.
You have been looking at the classification problems but still just a little recollection.
So classification is essentially a mapping between set of features to a set of level
or a particular level.
So in case of binary classification for example we have a record where each record has x which
are the attributes or features or independent variable whatever we may want to call it and
y is the class or the level or the output and in binary y is either 0 or 1.
In case of multi-class classification y can take more than two classes.
Classification task is to learn a model that maps the attribute set to the corresponding
class level so that whenever a new data point comes we can immediately through the model
we can immediately predict what is the likely level for this particular input test.
Now if you recall last week we have talked about three classifiers, knife base, nearest
neighbor and support vector machines.
Today we are going to talk about decision tree and we would talk about ensemble classifiers.
Example network or deep neural network which is like more popularly known as deep learning
that will be covered in subsequent lectures.
So let us first look at decision tree.
So before that let us take an example classification problem and this classification problem is
a simple problem.
So here we want to decide whether to play tennis on a particular day, so this is our
model or this is the model which we want to build that given the weather condition of
a particular day the model is going to predict whether there will be a tennis match or not.
Now in order to train this model let us say the club where the tennis is being played
they have collected last 14 days of data, the weather condition on those 14 days and
the corresponding status like whether actually a match was played or not.
So as you can see for example you look at day 1, day 1, in day 1 the outlook was sunny
temperature was hot, humidity was high and wind was weak and on that day there was no
game which was played.
On the other hand if you look at day 4 outlook was rain, temperature was mild, humidity was
high, wind was weak on that day a match was played.
So similarly you have such a history of 14 days and every day what was the weather condition
and whether a match was played or not.
Now since we are dealing with two levels here, one is whether a match was played or another
is whether the match was not played yes or no, so this is a binary classification problem
and this outlook, temperature, humidity and wind these four are the features.
So they are also called categorical features because they can pick values from certain
fixed categories.
So for example the outlook can be sunny, overcast or rain, temperature can be hot, mild or cool.
So similar like that, it can also have numerical features, now in this example there was no
such example of numerical features but let us say if instead of bucketizing the temperature
as like hot or mild or cool, if we just use the centigrade temperature like exactly the
temperature is less than 20 degree centigrade or 30 degree centigrade or 40 degree centigrade
in that case it would have been a numerical feature.
Now with this background let us see how a decision tree can be built using this training
data which we have.
So essentially we are going to construct a decision tree like this that where this is
a node, so this is also called a root node, these are internal nodes and these are the
leaf nodes.
So decision tree essentially enforce a hierarchical hierarchy of rules to make a prediction.
So this internal nodes and the root node they test the rule and in the leaf node you see
that ultimate decision is there.
So decision tree learning is essentially learning such a tree from the level training data as
we saw earlier those like 14 days of match data whether a match was played or not depending
on the weather condition.
Now the basic idea behind decision tree is generally very simple.
We would like to recursively partition the entire training data into homogeneous regions.
Now what is meant by homogeneous region?
homogeneous region is one where all the training input will have the same level.
So let us just see one example.
So let us say this is our entire training data with the corresponding levels.
So here as the picture suggests there are three levels red, blue and green and the training
data like all these dots denote a particular data point.
Now the goal of or in this case a homogeneous region is to divide the entire training space
or the data space into regions where only one type of level is present.
So for example here this is one homogeneous region because here there is only blue levels.
Similarly here there is there are only red data points.
Similarly you can continuously divide and eventually after this division like we have
just divided the entire training data space into smaller subspaces which we are calling
as homogeneous region where essentially there is just like one single class level data with
a single class level is present.
Now do we always want such a scenario like where all the points are just one class level?
Ideally yes but in reality they may still have some training data point which do not
belonging to the exactly one class level but the majority of the levels in a particular
region will be of one type and that constitutes a homogeneous region.
So now if we can let us say divide the entire training data into such homogeneous regions
in that case within each group we can simply fit a supervised learner and that supervised
learner is going to predict the majority level.
Now we will come or we will discuss this in more detail a little later.
Now let us look at what happens when a particular test input is given and how its level is predicted.
So let us say that we have divided the whole region into this homogeneous regions and essentially
homogeneous region means that each of the this black lines which have created the homogeneous
regions they correspond to some rule.
So the first rule is let us say that in terms of feature 1 or X1 our this line this black
line correspond to this rule whether X1 value is greater than 3.5 or not.
You see that actually this rule divides the entire space into this part and this part.
Now of course this itself is not sufficient.
So you need to also consider the feature 2 or X2.
So my first line here the line here this correspond to X2 is equal to 2.
So we are defining another rule whether X2 is greater than 2 or not.
If yes then we are talking about this region if no we are talking about this region.
Now if no we are talking about this region then this entire thing is only red.
So if a particular input falls here then we will immediately predict that has to be red.
On the other hand if you look at this particular region in this region X1 is greater than 3.5
X2 is also greater than 2.
So X1 greater than sorry this should be X1 greater less than 3.5 it is not greater than
so sorry for the typo.
So if X1 is less than 3.5 and X2 is greater than 2 we are essentially in this particular
region.
So there are a lot of red dots there.
So let me just change the color a little bit or also just like remove this.
So essentially we have now yeah so we have one rule whether X1 is less than 3.5 so that
actually that correspond to this particular line.
So this divides the entire space into two regions the right hand side and the left hand
side.
Now in the left hand side now our first rule is this line so this line correspond to X2
is equal to 2.
So if X2 is greater than 2 then we are talking about this region if X2 is less than 2 we
are talking about this region correct.
Now if X2 is greater than 2 in that case X2 is greater than 2 and X1 is less than 3.5
so that is this particular region.
So if any point comes here in that case it will be predicted as red.
When X1 is less than 3.5 and X2 is greater than 2 then we are talking about this particular
region and as the color suggest that region is green.
So now let us move to the right part so this correspond to X1 which is okay I am I think
sorry I am just making some silly mistakes.
So essentially this is actually 3.5 more than 3.5 so I just like didn't notice the yes
and no level.
So when X1 is 3.5 we are essentially in this region and in that region if X2 is greater
than 3 that means this.
So this is dividing it into again 2 regions the one lower and the one upper.
In the lower region our X1 value is greater than 3.5 and X2 value is greater than 3.
So in that case we are predicting so in that case we are predicting green otherwise we
are predicting red.
Now let us see for a particular test input what happens in this case the test input is
actually belonging to the green point like the test input is denoted as the black dot
here.
Now after this decision 3 is created now I am just going to predict what happens with
the test input.
Now see the test input the X1 value is greater than 3.5 that is not correct.
So it goes to the left hand side X2 is greater than 2 that is yes.
So in that case this actually followed this path and we make the decision that here the
class level is green.
So you see that once the decision tree is constructed properly it is a very efficient
algorithm at the test time.
So if you look at this particular example when a particular test input has come we just
made 2 comparisons we checked whether a particular feature X1 whether it is greater than 3.5
and whether another feature X2 whether that is greater than 2 that is it.
Only 2 feature value comparisons we have made.
On the other hand if we were to use something like a K nearest neighbor the K nearest neighbor
would have compared distances from all the training input.
So that way it is much, much costly at the test time because if there are in this example
there are so many training inputs.
Now if a particular test input has come in that case the test input would have been compared
with all the training inputs then we would have found the nearest let us say 5 or 6 neighbors
or 7 neighbors and then picked the level which is majority in the neighborhood.
But the initial comparison to figure out who are the actual neighbors that would have
costed a lot of time.
Now here the root node essentially actually consists of all the training input and it
decides like where to go as we move down the tree each internal node also deals with a
subset of training inputs and effectively the leaf nodes deal with the least possible
training input where there is not much variability in terms of the class levels.
So mostly the leaf nodes we try to make them deal with only homogeneous regions.
Now there are still some considerations when we are building decision trees what should
be the size of the shape of the tree.
So for example like what should be the number of internal nodes and leaf nodes.
So see that there is no rule saying that you have to only have two decisions against a
particular internal node.
So you could have had another decision like this.
So it is not necessary that every tree just need to have like two decisions.
So that is one the branching factor of internal node as I mentioned.
Then how many leaf nodes do you want to have?
How many internal nodes do you want to have?
What is going to be the depth of the tree?
Like is it going to be let us say three depth or four levels or five levels?
How much deep do you want to make the tree?
Then the second question is the split criteria at the internal node.
So we have a rule like earlier the point like where I was getting a little confused was because
of this comparison either the answer is yes or no and accordingly you would take one particular
root through the tree or path through the tree.
So to determine which is going to be this rule or which is going to be the condition
on which we are branching to different leaf nodes.
So that itself is something which we will have to decide.
So that is the split criteria.
So should we go for another classified to determine the split criteria or should we just do some
simplest test to just identify whether we are doing it correctly or not.
What to do at the leaf node?
So leaf node is making the final decision but if all are all levels are the same like
if it is truly homogeneous then there is no problem but sometimes you may not be able to
distinguish it very cleanly.
So you may have a mix of two class levels even in a leaf node.
So what to do in that case like should we make a constant prediction for each test input
which comes there or should we use something like a nearest neighbor based prediction but
only looking at the inputs which are there at the leaf node.
So these are many different options which we have.
The question is which one to pick.
Often time cross validation which we discussed in the last class cross validation is typically
used to decide many of these questions like whether we want to go with a particular size,
we want to go through a particular depth.
So all these things are typically decided based on the cross validation performance.
Now let us look at or let us spend a little bit more time on the split criteria what can
be done to figure out like how to split at internal nodes.
Now recall that root node deals with the entire training set when we come to the internal
nodes they typically receive a subset of all the training inputs.
But our idea is that whatever the splitting criteria may be we would want a scenario where
after the split it is made then in the next branch we want to reduce impurity as much
as possible.
So what is meant by impurity or on the other hand what is meant by a pure group or purity?
A pure group means that most of the inputs for that group will have the same level or
output.
So let us just look at two examples.
So let us say this was the internal node and in internal node we have four red data points
and four blue data points so this is the distribution.
So as you see that when the training data points came here you have equal number of
red data points equal number of blue data points.
Now suppose your criteria is such that it ended up having in the left hand side you ended
up having two red nodes and two or let us say two examples which are red and two blue
examples.
On the right hand side also you have two red examples two blue examples.
So this is not a very good split because you started with a uniform distribution of class
levels in that particular internal node if even after you split them if you end up getting
the same uniform distribution then there is no value of this splitting you are not helping
in the classification process rather compared to that a much better split is such which
even if it takes an uniform distribution of equal number of blue and red nodes but it
ends up dividing them in groups such that in each group either you get like a majority
of red levels and a minority of blue levels or you get a majority of blue levels and a
minority of red level.
So that way although you started with a uniform distribution you end up with a skewed distribution.
So this is actually considered as a good split and this intuition is utilized when we start
building a decision tree.
Now how do we measure this purity?
So purity is measured using a particular metric called entropy.
Entropy is a measure of purity.
So in very simple terms what entropy measures is the randomness in distribution alright.
So for example when we are dealing with a uniform distribution there is very high randomness
why so let us say that you close your eyes and you try to pick a sample from a particular
set of let us say set of balls.
Now the balls are either blue balls or red balls.
Now when there is a very high randomness and my eyes are closed there is almost equal probability
that I will pick a red ball or a blue ball.
You cannot say for certain or you cannot be certain that you are going to pick only one
colored ball because like your distribution is uniform so you have almost equal number
of red balls and blue balls so you have almost like 50% probability that you will pick a
red ball or a blue ball.
So in such cases where the randomness is very high the entropy measure will be high I will
come to how it is exactly measured but I am just giving you an intuition.
On the other hand let us say that you know that a particular set has most of the balls
there are blue.
Let us say 90% are blue balls and 10% are red balls.
In that case you are essentially dealing with even if you are just picking one ball randomly
there is a very high chance that the ball will be blue.
So here the randomness is much lower so in other words if you see that the probability
of both the options are almost equal in that case there is very high randomness.
If you see that the probability of one option is much higher than the probability of another
there is lower randomness.
So in the first case the entropy would be much higher.
In the second case the entropy would be much lower and this is why you started with uniform
distribution here.
So there the entropy was very high you ended up with a skewed distribution and in the skewed
distribution the entropy is low.
So we want a split which goes from high entropy to low entropy.
So low entropy means that there is high purity less uniform level distribution and we want
the split that give the highest or largest reduction in entropy before split versus after
split.
In fact this reduction is also called information gain.
So again going back to our example of this blue balls and red balls so essentially when
you are just blindly picking a ball there is a 50% in the initial case there was a 50%
chance that you pick a red ball versus a blue ball correct.
Now in the next distribution where you have 90% blue balls and 10% red balls you are more
certain.
So you have more information about what you are going to pick.
So you are now more confident about picking a blue ball.
So you have gained some inside information about like although you do not know for like
100% certainty that you are going to pick a blue ball but you are now much well equipped
to predict that I am going to pick a blue ball alright.
So this gain in information is defined as information gain this is another measure and
entropy as I mentioned entropy actually measures the purity of the distribution alright.
So let us now look at them in a bit more formal manner.
So we will cover the exact formula for them in just like in a couple of slides.
So basically the technique to split at internal node is such that every node decides which
outgoing branch and input should be sent to and this can be done by testing the value
of single feature at a time.
So in this case let us say I am just determining whether I am going to pick a particular single
feature and accordingly I am going to divide.
Now with this approach so on other hand like in one approach you just make a horizontal
split and in that approach all features and all possible values of each feature need to
be evaluated and we need to select the feature which we want to pick at every internal node
and on the other hand like you can also try to learn a classifier where we would have
to every internal node the decision is based on actually learning a decision boundary and
based on the decision boundary we will send it to the left child or the right child.
Now in general these are more common like where we look at a single feature pick the
one which is giving you the maximum benefit and in fact all ID3 C4.5 algorithm these are
very popular algorithms they all use this a single feature at a time concept.
On the other hand more advanced decision tree methods also use some internal classifiers
at every internal node so for example let us say you actually run a simple SVM to determine
the classes or the split at the internal level so this happens only at a advanced TT method.
So for now we are going to stick to this particular method where we are picking a single feature
at a time but the goal is to identify which feature is giving us the best possible result.
So for example here one feature may lead to an horizontal split of the training data another
feature may lead to a vertical split of the training data.
We have to compute the entropy before the split the entropy after the split and we are
going to pick the feature which leads to the highest possible or largest possible drop
in entropy as we mentioned in the earlier slide.
So essentially like there can be multiple questions for example given some training data so let
us say this training data was given and we ended up getting this particular decision
tree but how do we know whether this decision tree is the best possible or optimal decision
tree.
Now in general constructing decision tree is a very complex algorithmic problem in fact
those of you who have done some quotes on theoretical computer science would understand
that this problem is called NP heart problem.
So these are problems which are quite hard to solve and often time we use some kind of
a greedy strategy to construct a good decision tree.
Now to do this we use the training data to figure out which rules should be tested at
every node we will show some example there.
Now the question is that like how to decide which rules to test and in what order.
So we apply this so we look at the training data to figure out which rules to be tested
and we apply the same rules on the test input to route them along the tree until they reach
some leaf node where the prediction is going to be made.
So these rules are organized in the decision tree such that most informative rules are
tested first.
So note the word most informative so this actually gives you the intuition that we want
to go after information gain that means the drop in entropy before the split and after
the split.
So the rules are this is kind of decided based on that so as the animation such is like how
to assess the informativeness of a rule.
So essentially informativeness of a rule is of related to the extent of the purity.
More informative rules yield purer splits as we will see here in the example.
So again we are back to the playing tennis example.
So let us say that every internal node in the decision tree which we are building for
the playing tennis example is going to test the value of one feature.
So if you remember there are these features like outlook, temperature, humidity and wind
and based on these features and the corresponding values we are making a decision whether game
will be played or not and we want to come up with a decision tree like this.
But the question is that whether outlook should be the root node or should humidity be the
root node or wind should be the root node.
So now we will have to decide why does it make more sense to test the feature outlook
first or in other words like to put outlook in the root node.
So here the answer is that of all the features it is most informative.
Now of course like I am not an oracle like who can tell that without actually computing
this so we are going to compute this but for the moment just assume that outlook is the
most informative feature and that is why we have put outlook in the root node.
In fact it has the highest information gain as the root node.
Now let us come to formally define entropy and information gain.
So let us just assume that we have a set of labeled input S.
So this S you can think of your training data set and we have C classes.
So C in case of binary classification C means 2 classes like class 1 and class 2.
If it is multiclass classification you may have multiple classes like class 1, class 2,
class 3 and PC you can get as the fraction of inputs which belong to class C.
So there is a particular class C and we are defining the input.
Now entropy of this whole set is defined as hs to be minus summation of P log P or in
other words PC is the fraction of class C inputs we take that and then we multiply that by
logarithmic of PC and we sum all of them up and this is a negative sum.
So we take the negative of that and then sum all of them.
Now suppose so this is what we are getting so this we are getting at the set S level.
So this is let us say set S, this has class let us say cross and tick.
For every class we are determining the fraction of class C inputs.
So for example here the fraction of class cross input is half, this is the fraction
of class tick input this is also half.
So we are just going to take like half log half and 2 times this and then we are going
to take the sum.
So sum is essentially in this case so when I say sum so this is essentially we are when
we are just like summing it up like half log half it we are talking about like 2 additions
of this is 2 and then we put a minus.
So this is going to be the entropy of this particular set S.
Now suppose this S set is then further divided to be 2 subset S1 and S2 and S1 let us say
we have 1 tick and 1 cross, S2 we have 1 tick and 1 cross.
Basically we are going to compute the entropy of S1 entropy of S2 and then we are going
to compute information gain as the reduction of entropy after split.
So HS we know HS is that original entropy which we computed then we computed HS1 HS2
so we are taking HS1 we are taking HS2 and we are normalizing with respect to the number
of data points went to each of this subsets.
So we are now just computing this so this was our original entropy this is the resultant
entropy after the split and we are taking an weighted sum of that and information gain
is the difference between these two.
So this was after split and this is before split so this is before split this is after
split we take the difference as information gain.
Now in general uniform sets like where all classes are roughly equally present actually
have very high entropy.
Just recall the red ball blue ball example which I gave that when there is high randomness
so then there is high entropy but when the distribution is skewed the entropy is lower.
So if you can go from a higher entropy system to a lower entropy system we will have more
information gain and we will try to get rules which can lead to this.
So in our earlier example we see that we actually went so in one kind of split so in this split
we started with an uniform distribution we ended up having two uniform distributions.
So this is not a very good split because here the entropy decay was not much in fact in
this case like you can compute and see that it is almost like information gain is 0.
Well on the other hand here you are starting with an uniform distribution but you ended
up with two skewed distribution so it has very high entropy these two are having low
entropy so here the information gain will be much higher.
So this is a much better split compared to this split.
So whatever feature is giving us a split like this we are going to pick that compared to
another feature which are giving us split like this.
So this is a no this is yes when we are trying to select a feature on which we want to split.
Now let us try to work it out using our tennis example.
So first for this whole data we have 4 features again outlook, temperature, humidity, wind.
Now let us just for example take the feature wind and let us try to consider whether taking
feature wind as the root node that will lead to a good reduction in entropy that means
a high information gain.
Now root contains all the examples so in this case if you just work it out the H s will
become 0.94 when we are taking the wind.
So why out of 14 days there were nine days for which the game was played sorry so out
of nine days so you had the wind weak wind on nine of the days and in five of the days
you had wind was strong.
Now so that is why like you got this kind of entropy when you are only considering once
again let me just clear this out once and then we can just start again.
So let us just use this example let us take what happens when we take let us say wind
as the root node.
So now root contains all the examples now in this case wind has two data points like
either the wind is strong or wind is weak and you have two scenarios whether the match
was played or the match was not played.
Now nine out of 14 days the match was played and five out of 14 days the match was not
played.
So this was the overall entropy value when we are considering all the training data.
So this is 9 by 14 because this is the case for which match was played log 9 by 14 and
then like you know that this is a negative sum.
So again like minus 5 by 14 log 5 by 14 and you get an entropy of 0.94.
Now based on the feature wind we now just distinguish them between weak and strong.
So this is the set of inputs where the wind was weak and this is the set of inputs where
the wind was strong out of all the cases where wind was weak six days match was played two
days match was not played.
So this has an entropy 0.811 on the other hand is strong that means the cases where
the wind was strong three days match was played three days match was not played the entropy
is one.
So if you look at the overall information gain when we use wind as the root feature
it is HS minus S weak S strong and this boils down to 0.048.
So this was my information gain.
In the similar procedure we can compute the information gain for outlook if we used outlook
as the root feature we can compute the information gain for humidity if we used humidity as the
root feature and temperature as the root feature.
Now we combine the information gain of wind was 0.048, outlook was 0.246, humidity was
0.151 and temperature was 0.029.
Now if we compare all of them we can see that 0.246 was the highest value.
So the outlook feature actually gave the best possible information gain and hence, hence
we pick outlook as the root node.
Now this is just to compute the root node.
We will also have to compute the internal nodes.
So how to grow the tree that what to do at the next level, what would be the internal
node or what would be the feature which we will use as the splitting criteria.
So we actually iterate this whole process for every node along the line.
So once we select the root node then we follow it up with like other internal nodes and we
continue doing that and we continue growing the tree.
So first it was outlook, then we have to decide what to take.
So we compute, so for the level 2 we can compute the information gain again.
So for temperature the information gain was 570, for humidity the information gain was
970 and wind the information gain was 0.019.
Now since humidity led to the highest information gain, so we pick humidity as the next feature
at level 2 left node.
Similarly for level 2 right node we will pick another one.
Now here for example there was one extra leaf node or one leaf node where we got a scenario
where every point here was leading to one class level ES.
So if you look at this when outlook is overcast we have 4 days and all 4 days match was played.
So this particular case we do not need any further split because it is already we are
at a point where every class level here is pointing to ES.
So we are only concerned about the left node and right node.
For left node we got humidity which actually led to the best highest information gain.
We will do it for the right hand side and we can verify by computing the information
gain that here taking the feature wind actually leads to highest information gain.
So here we take wind.
Now this can go on and on right.
So we will have to also stop growing a tree.
So we started with the root node, we now have multiple internal nodes, we also got some
leaf nodes.
At certain time we will have to decide that okay enough of it we just stop the process
of building the tree at this point.
So what is the stopping criteria?
So we stop when either the node consists of only training examples having the same level.
So if it has become pure, I mean there is no way we can further divide it or we have
although like the set has not become pure but we have tried out all possible features.
So there is no more features to test.
Third is that the decision tree starts to overfit.
Now this is something earlier Sabasachi was alluding in his the demonstrations that look
at certain time your model can also overfit like where you can do very well with your
training data but as soon as you hit a test data point then your accuracy start going
low.
In fact this can be checked by looking at the validation set accuracy that ideally the
validation set accuracy should be high like we do not want to do very well only with the
training data, we want to do well with the test data.
So now if we continue trying to fit the model so that it does very well with the training
data we may lose out on the test time performance.
So this is called overfitting and at certain point the decision tree will start to overfit
and we close or we stop growing the tree at that point.
So here if we can look at let us say this is the test accuracy and this is the validation
accuracy you see at certain point the test accuracy may continue to grow but the validation
accuracy may start dropping and at that point we should stop growing the tree further.
And one thing is important is that like if we want to obsess too much on purity then
it can lead to overfitting.
So we might be okay with let us say a scenario where 80% of the class levels are of one type
and 20% are of another type that is okay because that will help us prevent the tree from going
too much.
So it is okay to have leaf node that is not fully pure let us say that the probability
of red can be 3 by 8, probability of green can be 5 by 8 and we can simply take the majority
value and that is perfectly fine.
So at this moment let us just take a small break and let us convene again after 5 minutes